foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to Bleacher Report
fantasy football live presented by State
Farm
my name is Adam Levitan I am from
establish the Run joined by Mike Leone
of establish the run to hang out today
talk about some spots for week one is
finally Upon Us Leonia we're going to
talk about some spots some matchups for
guys in week one how's it going today
it's you know week one's always a bit of
a whirlwind but I'm excited for real
games to be set in actual lineups and to
get some results pouring it
we've been talking about these guys for
the last five months or so and trying to
think about what they're going to do all
of that will go out the door because we
will learn so much more here in week one
I am super super super excited to figure
it out we're gonna start here we're
gonna get to Five Guys that we think are
really good starts or really good plays
in week one here in a second one guy
that actually didn't make the list that
I wanted to get your take on was Jamal
Williams of the Saints we know that
Alvin Kamara is suspended we also know
that Kendra Miller missed practice today
the thing for people is like a lot of
people probably took Jamal Williams as
their fourth running back on their team
or something he was going in the 10th
11th 12th round they're like well God I
can I start Jamal Williams might
probably have better running backs but
man if you're not going to start Jamon
Williams this week when Khmer is
suspended and Kendra Miller has a
hamstring injury when are you gonna
start him so I get that that's a spot
but man it'd be hard for me not to start
Jamal any thoughts on him this week yeah
I mean we've got them projected for
double-digit PPR points you know the
difficulty with Williams is just it
could be a bit of an ugly game
environment I can see the pace being
kind of slow and the uncertainty with
him is how much he's gonna deliver in
the past game you know last year for
Detroit he had a very clearly defined
role which was predicated upon a ton of
goal line volume if he you know doesn't
run his pure there and has the same
involvement in the past game it could be
disappointing so I think he's got a
higher floor than someone like DeAndre
Swift where we just don't know the usage
for Philadelphia but if you're looking
for the ceiling then you might want to
just gamble on Swift Just because I
think there's a bit more efficiency
upside and pass catching upside yeah for
sure and I always thought that Jamal
Loomis was kind of just a guy right he's
not going to create stuff on his own he
needs to get what's blocked he needs to
score touchdowns from inside the five
yard line but yeah I do think he's a
reasonable start this weekend if he
drafted him God it's hard not to all
right
let's get to some guys that we think are
really strong plays this week in week
one Joe Mixon had a rough
2023 I'm sorry 2022 season he was not
very efficient he lost a ton of time to
semajp Ryan in the playoffs too I mean
we saw the Bengals go to samaje piran
over Joe Mixon a bunch now samaja piran
is in Denver they did not do a lot to
replace samaje piran they drafted Chase
Brown in the fifth round they have
trayvion Williams Who's Back healthy
they have Chris Evans who's kind of a
pass catching specialist but I could
actually see Nixon's role this year
being bigger than it was last year
against the Browns
this week any thoughts on that spot for
Joe Mixon yeah I mean you hit on it the
competition for backfield touches is
just minimal right now I have some
concerns like over the course of the
season if like mixing starts to wear
down and Chris Evans maybe flashes but
heading into the year it's it's the same
guys as last year except without piran
who is the main guy and we saw him
mixing if you looked at any expected
Fantasy Point metrics he was among the
league leaders because he's getting the
goal line touches sometimes he plays
past down you know uh passing downs but
even when he doesn't he's kind of
getting a double digit Target chair just
out of Base work which is really good
for a fantasy back so you kind of hit
the trifecta where you're getting like
this big workload overall you're getting
enough reception volume and you're on a
team that's just consistently good they
have a team total of 25 this week
they're going to put a point so yeah
mixing's a must start for sure yeah I
mean
I think people underestimate how good
Joe burrow is at throwing accurately and
consistently to the running back
position this goes back to his time
at LSU and so even if Joe Mixon only
plays on first and second down which I'm
not sure will definitely be the case but
even if that's the case like leonie said
I still think that he gets a bunch of
pass catching work here really
interesting game between the Bengals and
the Browns uh for sure
controversial guide this off season was
Anthony
Richardson I mean
if you watch college football last year
if you watched Anthony Richardson
everyone thought this guy could not
throw was broken can't be an NFL
quarterback will never be able to
complete a pass in the NFL then he goes
in the top five in the NFL draft and
there are so many different opinions out
there on Anthony Richardson I'm curious
what you thought of him in the preseason
and he gets his NFL debut here in a home
game against the Jaguars
yeah the preseason stuff was a lot of
confirmation bias if you were kind of
anti-anthony Richardson you probably saw
the six for 17 line and we're like this
this guy can't throw this is gonna be a
disaster if you were pro-anthony
Richardson you saw him run a little bit
and more importantly you saw the Colts
running in Up Tempo offense at a fast
pace and seeing machine so I can carry
that over from the Eagles and for
Fantasy honestly that's what we care
about more is he gonna run are they
gonna run a ton of plays so uh I think
they are and I think this matchup in
particular week one you know our path
Foreman at ETR has got this as his top
pesop matchup meaning this can be a fast
game both these teams are going to play
up in Tempo Jacksonville did it last
year the Colts are going to be different
than they were last year it's a dome
game so I think it's a really good spot
and even if the Colts are trailing a
decent bit I mean dropbacks for
Richardson are good so I don't think
it's going to be pretty but if you're in
a league where it's standard scoring
four point passing touchdowns 1.25 yards
passing it's not going to take a whole
time from Richardson to beat a lot of
these pure pocket passers yeah my
question on the original is always the
ceiling right I think people get it
confused these rushing super athletic
quarterbacks to me they have a better
floor than ceiling in other words it's
gonna be really hard for Anthony
Richardson not to get 10 fantasy points
because he's going to run and he's going
to do these weird things and he's going
to scramble around and you might get a
tush push uh goal line touchdown like uh
strange steiken did with the Eagles but
in order to hit the ceilings now you
need to do Jalen hurts type things you
need to do Josh Allen type things I'm
not sure that's in in the Richardson's
range so to me Richardson would be more
of a floor play than a ceiling play if
you follow uh what I'm saying there
yeah absolutely I see in the comments uh
Luke Collier asks should I start you
know should I start Walker or Gibbs and
PPR I thought I was uh gonna be Jamal
Williams question but like we're Team
Jamir Gibbs right
so the question uh Jamir Gibbs uh versus
Kenneth Walker I mean before Jameson
Williams gets back and he's spending for
six games beyond the Monroe same brown
there is dust for the Lions to throw to
and if you look at the profile of Jamir
Gibbs coming out of college I mean he is
an awesome awesome awesome
pass catching Prospect and I think he'll
get some of the base work
Russian ball behind uh David Montgomery
also so yeah it would be I love this
spot for Kenneth Walker for sure against
the Rams and we'll talk about him more
uh in a little bit here but I think
it'll be Jamir Gibbs uh for me there
over uh Kenneth Walker
um for Mace Windu he says what about
putting Jamal Williams in the flex since
Kendra Miller is doubtful yeah I think
I'd be trying to get Jamal Williams into
my lineup personally for me if you
drafted him like if you don't use him
this week uh when are you going
to use him all right
third start that we have here is Brian
Robinson and Brian Robinson was going a
little bit earlier than Jamal Williams
in most drafts similar to Jamal Williams
though this is I think an awesome spot
you get Brian Robinson in a home game
against his Arizona team that is one of
the most Talent devoid teams that we've
seen in the NFL in a really really long
time only expected to win three or four
games by the market in the 17 Game
season it's just embarrassing they're
going to be starting Josh Dobbs in this
game they're going across the country
from Arizona to Washington I mean you
couldn't lay out a better setup for
Brian Robinson the power back now he was
not great last year Leone however dude
got shot before the season I mean get
give the guy a break okay I think he can
be better this year just from an
efficiency perspective and I don't know
for sure that Antonio Gibson is going to
be like a true 50 50. I think if
anything especially in this game script
in this likely game Flow it could lean
more towards Robinson so I really like
Robinson in this spot it would be
Robinson over Gibson for me and if I had
Robinson on my season-long team I would
be trying to start him here any thoughts
on the Washington backfield
yeah I mean the matchup's perfect like
this is gonna be maybe the best spot to
start Brian Robinson all year long at
least while Antonio Gibson is healthy
there's not going to be a better spot
than this there's seven point favorites
in this game and they might split time
over the course of the Season 50 50 but
Robinson's the guy who's gonna be
playing from ahead like he's between the
tackles guy he's the grinder we saw
games last year where he got like 20
carries for you know 66 yards they just
kept giving it to him so as you said you
know we're gonna give him a little bit
of a break on the efficiency thing if
that can improve this year and I don't
know if you noted this but in the
preseason Sam Hall was throwing to the
running backs a lot more than they did
last season so there's even some pass
catching upside for Robinson like he's
thought of as just like this pure rusher
but having that pass catching upside on
shutdowns even if it's in base work is
is going to be important for his fantasy
sailing yeah I think the B enemy stuff
like Pacheco McKinnon right uh Brian
Robinson is the new Pacheco and uh
Antonio Gibbs Gibson is the new McKinnon
for every enemy
I think Gibson might have a little bit
bigger role than that but I think that's
the idea
to think about there
next one we have is DK Metcalf
um Jackson Smith and jigba fractured his
wrist about three weeks ago had surgery
has been back practicing for a week
sounds like he's gonna play but before
the Jackson Smith and takeover
happens and we're very high on Jackson
Smith and jigba eventually taking over
not taking over but being a very
important part of this pass game before
that happens DK Metcalf to me is the
alpha while Tyler Lockett is aging up a
bit Deacon Metcalf is entering his prime
jsn has this wrist issue and this Rams
defense
I can't even I mean all I do is look at
this stuff all day I don't even know who
half their defense is and so it's a
really good spot I think for all the
Seahawks we'll talk about in a second a
little bit more here but certainly DK
Metcalf I think one of my favorite plays
this week
I assume you're on this DK Metcalf stuff
leonio though I know you are a kind of a
lockout jsn guy too I'm rocking the Rams
jersey right now the old school Isaac
Bruce here but uh I'm with you this Rams
deep this is going to be different than
what we've seen before
um in past years for the Rams the
defense is gonna be really bad and the
fun thing about Seattle is that we kind
of make fun of Pete Carroll for being a
boomer but last year their pass rate
over expectation was pretty neutral you
know they threw at a higher rate than we
thought they were going to and Gino was
extremely accurate posting like super
high completion percentages even when he
played partially the season before super
high completion percentage and you know
back Castle is guys that's tough to
project but he's got the big playability
and he always is among the league
leaders in End Zone Target so that
touchdown upside's huge this is gonna be
one of the higher team totals that
Seattle has all season long definitely
fire him up
um question from Chad from dubia this is
a good one for you Leone dubia says
start leviska Chanel you heard it here
first Leoni has a long and winding
history with laviska Chanel I honestly
had not even thought about
leviska Chenault uh I do not think that
I would be starting with this weekend
that's not missing something on Mr visca
Leone now I think people get excited for
these Gadget type players they're going
to be you know quote unquote used in a
lot of different ways and then they end
up with like maybe four touches total
for the game so
um I you'd have to really really deep I
can't even say I have libiscus channel
on any team that I've I've drafted this
year
uh Pierce Davis says Jahan Dotson or Zay
flowers in the flex this week we do know
that Terry McLaren is gonna play in this
game now Tara McLaren had the toe issue
is going to make it back and play in
this game against Arizona meanwhile Jose
flowers first round rookie for the
Ravens has a really good spot home game
against the Texans here who do you
prefer between Zay uh and John Dodson
this week
that is so incredibly tough I know our
projections at ETR have it slid the way
of Jahan Dotson I think if you're
playing for a big time ceiling though I
expect Baltimore to come up throwing a
way more aggressively than they ever had
at a faster pace and I know people are
probably worried a little bit about the
game script because they're gonna be
playing from ahead most likely in this
game against Houston but
I think they're going to put up so many
points and you know flowers Ricky wide
receiver he might break out in a big way
just like right out of the gate so it
kind of leans a flowers even though
datsun's a little bit safer for your
projected targets uh I went to Penn
State a long time ago and John Dodson
went to Penn State and so we're close
personal friends so I I actually am
going to go with John Dotson here hoping
that Terry mccorm is limited but I think
less Target competition right like would
it shock you if early in the season
Odell actually looks good Odell Beckham
actually looks good like it would not
Shock me if Odell comes out and earns
eight targets from Lamar Jackson in week
one and I do not think that would be
good first day flowers if that happens
right whereas on Washington I'm pretty
confident that Dodson is going to be
among their target leaders so I'll go
Jahan Das in there but certainly really
really really
close uh Travie says Juju or Pacheco
over Gabe Davis
in the flex now
um and would not be Juju for me it would
either be Pacheco or Gabe Davis Pacheco
was coming off of uh shoulder and wrist
issues seems like he's perfectly fine
now meanwhile Gabe Davis had a very very
frustrating year that last year I think
he's gonna be much better this year but
the week one matchup is not good facing
the Jets who I think will have a very
very good defense so any thoughts there
Leone Pacheco versus Gabe Davis
yeah I think I'm Pacheco on this one I
mean there's some concern that he was a
little banged up over the off season and
but it seems like the team's not
concerned and he's going to be pretty
clearly the lead here we know they're
going to split some with Pacheco or with
McKinnon do you expect CH to have some
involvement But ultimately uh I think
the four ceiling combination this is
going to be a bit of a shootout even
with Travis Kelsey potentially out
between Kansas City and Detroit so give
me Pacheco and I did like in the playoff
game last year you know he was catching
a few more passes in base which is
always good to see but the rush
efficiency the TD upside from him is
really why you're starting him yeah I I
think
um one thing that I would say about
Pacheco stuff team play calling I know
you look at and work on a lot how much
would you change Kansas City's play
calling to be more run heavy if Travis
Kelsey misses this game because I do
think it's better for Pacheco if Kelsey
is out I think the offense would
probably be less efficient but they
would probably have a more run based
game plan than if Kelsey plays
yeah it's honestly it's really tough to
project because it's somewhat
counterintuitive generally the line here
has moved about two points right I think
it was like six or six and a half for
Kansas City it's down to four and a half
for Kansas City generally as the spread
gets tighter if you're the favorite you
know we would expect you to pass more
just because the game scripts that
you're likely you're more likely to be
trialing than you were if you were a
seven point favorite for example so
um but at the same time when you lose
the critical part of the past game uh
you know it it doesn't always match up
with the way the pure math is going to
say so we kind of have it neutral in
terms of the past right where uh yes we
expect them to pass a little bit less
than normal with Kelsey but then the
spread has also come down two points and
that cancels each other out to an extent
so I think it might be net negative just
because Kansas City's expected to score
less points than they were prior to you
know Kelsey likely being out okay let's
move to the fifth guy that we like spot
this week and that is Marvin Mims now
Marvin Mims was a second round rookie
Sean Payton's first ever draft in charge
of the Broncos he trades up to get
Marvin Mims since he did that
they lost Tim Patrick they lost KJ
Handler I'd consider Jerry Judy doubtful
for this game with a hamstring and
they're facing the Raiders this week I
think a really good spot for Marvin Mims
now it's hard because he wasn't like the
cleanest Prospect coming out of college
this is his first NFL game I get it can
be hard to pull the trigger here I do
think that he's gonna play a ton though
opposite Courtland Sutton what do you
think about these rookies and not an
elite rookie this is we're not talking
about like Jamar Chase or Mario Cooper
or Julio Jones first game we're talking
about Marvin mimm's first career game
and relying on him what do you think
about that Leoni yeah I mean I know as a
prospect a lot of kind of the analytics
nerds really liked Marvin Mims but that
that was sort of relative to expectation
and to your point you know the
expectation wasn't super high for Mims
and then things break incredibly right
for him in terms of his playing time
with those injuries and if you look at
the rest of the wide receiver group I
mean we've got targets for Brandon
Johnson Philip Dorsett
um you know we're giving a lot of
targets to Greg Dawson who you know
really hasn't earned them in a big way
in the past there's just not much here
besides Cortland sudden and a lot of
check Downs to the running back and do
you think that Mims has you know the
downfield ability to break a big play
here so I like Mims you know if I had
a Christian Kirk type in the sixth round
or whatever that I drafted I I don't
think I'd be I think you'd be too
aggressive to start Marvin Mims over
that but there's definitely some
scenarios especially in deeper weed
deeper leagues where he's a weak one
flex play agreed agreed I will say that
Russ is best ASP of his game right now I
think is throwing the Deep ball and I
think that's where Marvin Mims excels as
well all right let's jump into this new
segment fantasy bundles presented by
State Farm we're bundling your home and
auto insurance is just another way to
save with the personal price plan we're
gonna talk about some Duos
that work bundling together I think the
first one is interesting we already
mentioned the spot for Seattle Kenneth
Walker and Tyler Lockett now people are
going to say oh what about Zach sharp
any people are also going to say well
running back and wide receiver have
negative correlation I don't think that
that stuff is overblown a bit when
Kenneth Walker is playing they're
getting a lot of first down they're
running a lot of uh plays Tire lockets
moving the chains whatever it's more
chance for Kenneth Walker Etc so I think
you can use these guys together Walker
and lock it even if it's not a perfect
correlation it's just such a home run
spot for Seattle so we already mentioned
Metcalf I wanted to also include Walker
and lock it in here and not leave them
behind in this awesome
spot any thoughts on them Leone yeah I'm
you know Kenneth Walker is one of my
highest drafted running backs this year
with charbonnet a little worried that at
times he might cut into some of the pure
pass catching stuff but similar to the
Brian Robinson San Antonio Gibson
conversation like it's kind of the nut
spot week one or we don't have to worry
about that as much you know they're five
and a half Point favorites over La could
see that spread even getting larger and
like this is the guy that can break a
home run at any point in time you know
he's got that Elite rushing Prospect
profile that not a lot of backs in the
NFL have so I'm always betting on that
and I totally agree with your point
where
don't worry too much about stacking
teammates if you have a team that's
going to score a lot of points and is
somewhat condensed offensively we've
seen even in you know daily fantasy
sports we've seen tournaments be won by
multiple teammates that you wouldn't
expect just because you know when the
offense rolls everybody kind of rolls
second one is guy we already mentioned
Brian Robinson I think the interesting
thing to talk about here though is
combining him with Commander's defense
as a bundle and we talked about
correlation a little bit already we know
for sure is a positive correlation is
these kind of early down touchdown heavy
running backs like Brian Robinson and
the team's defense Cardinals are going
to start Josh Dobbs in this game and so
I think playing Commander's defense with
Brian Robinson makes plenty of sense
there there's a ton of defenses to like
though this week for sure Leone any
thoughts on b-rob and the Washington
defense
yeah he's gonna be really highly
correlated with them because uh the game
script stuff that we mentioned already
so I absolutely love that one I'll also
throw in a third bundle here Trevor
Lawrence to Calvin Ridley the new
edition for the Jacksonville Jaguars I
think you know Trevor Lawrence's second
year with Doug Peterson he really
improved over the course the second half
of last season they're going to be Up
Tempo we've already hit on the pace in
this game against the Colts and now
Calvin Ridley comes in early in the off
season some concerns over the rust there
but you know we've seen enough from him
and training camp and the preseason
games that
um I I'm not too concerned especially
out of the gate so I'm expecting really
high ceiling performances from both
players to start week one yeah I mean
expecting this game to be very very fast
between Jacksonville and indy as we
already talked about on the turf out
there good spot for Calvin really to
make his return all right
let's do oh actually let's get to a
couple chat questions from John Foles he
says how do we feel about Asner Madison
in week one
playing the Bucks in Minnesota I like
Alexander Madison man I I think people
are overestimating how much Tai Chandler
and other running backs will cut into
Alexander Madison's workload I think
when the dust settles on Sunday Augusta
Madison will have 70 of the running back
touches and in today's NFL that is a ton
and so I like Madison I think I'm gonna
like him a lot of weeks and I like him
in week one
um yeah yeah I'm with you
um
I think especially early in the season
that workload's gonna be real good for
Madison and another Vikings question we
got in chat Dorne asks start Kadarius
Tony or Jordan Addison in PPR
I yeah we're expecting Tony to be active
and with Travis Kelsey probably out here
I think I'm gonna go to Tony I just
think there's a bit more upside and
security you know I don't really say
security with Tony but even if he
doesn't play a ton of snaps he's gonna
have a high Target per route run they're
going to design some plays for him I
love Jordan Addison over the course this
season but I don't know what his role is
going to be out of the gate so I'm
starting to Darius Tony there yeah I
mean the question on Addison is does he
have last year's Adam thielen role out
of the gate Adam thielen ran the second
most routes in the entire NFL last year
or will some of that go to KJ Osborne
out of the gate certainly interesting
all right
let's get to them guys some guys who may
not have the best matchup in week one
let's start with Marquis Brown facing
this commanders team
it's tough man Josh Dobbs I think is
a career backup
sub average Quarterback now that doesn't
mean that Marquis Brown can't hit right
it doesn't mean that Marquis Brown can't
do well
it's just harder I think and the four
ceiling combo is capped more if you had
Marquis Brown on your team here Leone
what are you thinking now that we know
Josh Dobbs is starting week one
I mean it's right on the fence I do
think Marquis Brown's legitimately good
and he could still rack up a bunch of
targets even if he's someone inefficient
I'd say the biggest concern is generally
in these spots If You're Gonna Play the
wide receiver on a bad team you want
them to be throwing the ball a lot and
you know with Ganon here defensive guy
it's gonna be a change from Cliff like
they ran a bunch of plays last year they
were Up Tempo we have them projected for
the lowest place run for week one like
they're not going to run a ton of plays
and they might not even pass as much as
they should relative to the game script
so that's the biggest concern for me
with Marquis and I think in in most
leagues I have somebody else that I'll
go to that I feel better about and you
know maybe Marquis will be back in my
lineup week two if if Dobbs is a bit
better in the play Collins better than
I'm fearful it might be sure
I think that's totally fair second one
that I think is a bit thin is Damien
Pierce going on the road to face this
Ravens team I mean offensive line
injuries and I was somewhat optimistic
that Texans would have a mediocre
offensive line this year they have been
decimated by injury and I think Devin
Singletary might be more annoying than
people are giving him credit for and so
for Damian Pierce to go on the road as a
10-point dog when we last year we did
not see Damien Pierce playing on Pass
Downs it's concerning to me for sure on
Damien Pierce any thoughts on him
against Baltimore here
yeah I mean frankly I'd rather play JK
Dobbins on the other side of this I
think their adps were switched for much
of the off season but I I'd go with
Dobbins and take kind of the point
scoring upside there and we had them
projected similarly with Dobbins higher
in ceiling though when you look at the
ceiling projections I'm with you with
Piers where I mean the preseason usage
was great and shows that maybe he'll be
full Workhorse but Devin singletary's
Advanced rushing numbers have always
been really good and I don't know I just
kind of want to see how he's utilized
first I think there's I think there's a
low four here if the utilization is
amazing you know again similar the
Marquise Brown thing like those concerns
are gone start them right away again
week two but
um you've probably got somebody else
that you feel better about week one and
that's the thing we're gonna learn so
much in week one like Damien Pierce
comes out and plays on every third and
five plus and CJ Stroud has a really
high running back Target rate like
that's great but we're gonna learn so
much in week one let's go to the third
guy we're a bit worried about in week
one Naji Harris here and so
really tough matchup right I mean San
Francisco has been very very good
against the Run they've invested so much
Capital into their defensive front seven
and we get Jalen Warren now breathing
down Naji Harris's neck I think it's
gonna be
65-35 in touches in favor of Naji Harris
somewhere around there but if it went to
60 40
or 55-45 it wouldn't necessarily shock
me so we have workload concerns for Naji
and we have match-up concerns for Naji
here now that said if you have not
generous on your team you probably used
like a third or fourth round pick on him
and it's really hard to pinch your third
or fourth round pick so I get it but
this is a really tough spot what do you
think about najib yeah I I was thinking
about that too I mean I almost want to
work the trade market right away here
before week one uh because it is it is
hard to bench your third round pick and
it's gonna be even harder to move him if
it is a disappoint like if it's a split
60 40 out of the gate I don't think it's
gonna get better rest to season and I do
think Jalen Warren especially like on
passed on stuff could could be a real
thorn on the side of nausea and it is
you know it's a tight spread but
projected to be a negative game script
fourth fade one we might disagree on a
little bit for the guys who don't those
of you who don't know Leone is a
Baltimore uh Buffalo Bills Homer he
actually jumps uh off of Vans uh face
first into picnic tables and so he is
not happy that we have Dalton Kincaid on
here however
I am always concerned with rookie tight
ends I am always concerned with rookies
right out of the gate in the pass
catching role and Dawson Knox is
actually good and so if they don't have
a planned role for Dawn Kincaid to be
like in every down slot receiver I have
some concerns
that maybe he's not gonna be out there
enough period now it's a tight end
position right so it doesn't take a lot
to be a good start at a tight end
position I think Leone probably has a
more bullish case on Don Kincaid here
against the Jets but yeah go ahead on
Kincaid Leone
yeah it's good timing Ryan figgin chat
was asking about our thoughts on Kincaid
so we have him up here and I'm more
bullish overall but I I do think there's
some concern like he's not going to play
traditional tight end stuff and I know
Pat crane of legendary upside has looked
at you know when tight ends really have
a big ceiling they're involved a lot in
like play action opportunities and their
total routes run is really good and can
Kincaid really get there on like a 50
route share I'm hoping it's going to be
more like 70 percent
I think week one again like I might play
it a little bit more conservatively but
at the same time sort of depends who
you're thrown out there like a lot of
these tight ends are risky like even the
safe guys have such a low floor that
there's part of me that just wants to
throw Kincaid out there uh just because
I think if we're wrong and he does have
a bigger role out of the gate the
ceiling just gonna be so much higher
than like adult and Schultz type where
I'm willing to kind of take that gamble
especially in like a more efficiency
based League where it's half PPR and I
think the touchdown upside is going to
swing Kincaid's way over a lot of those
other mediocre tight ends yeah I mean I
would start Higby over Kincaid right we
know Cooper cup is out like I think
Tyler Higby could get eight or nine
Targets in this game and to me that's
way safer than Dawn Kincaid I'd also
play Someone like in joku or friarmouth
over Kincaid uh also
um for me all right last one here on the
Fades is Quentin Johnston now this is a
first round rookie wide receiver in a
very good offense with a very good
quarterback typically that's exciting
however Big Mike Williams is there
Keenan Allen is there pretty good Target
earners Austin Eckler's there pretty
good Target earner Gerald Everett is
there and all the rhetoric out of Los
Angeles and I'm not saying this is
definitely true but all the rhetoric is
that Josh Palmer is currently ahead of
Quentin Johnson I'm not saying I buy
that but that's the rhetoric out of the
reports
I think I'd probably want to wait and
see if Quentin Johnston can earn targets
before I got him into my lineup this is
the kind of player who we draft in the
8th 9th 10th round because we think
he'll help us at the very end of the
season when it's most important so I
think Clinton Johnson's a pretty easy
bench this week Leone any disagreement
there
no super easy bench and if your league
mates who drafted him you know sometimes
people draft these rookies and they
don't realize the bet they're making
which as you said it's end of season
upside and you know if they flash early
that's great that's a bonus but you
gotta be patient and if your league
mates aren't and they drop him I would
scoop him up and stash him like I really
want a piece of this offense I think
he's going to surpass Josh Palmer on
Talent by the end of the season I think
there's odds that Keenan Allen or Mike
Williams get injured given their
histories lots of way he can make it
onto the field for an offense we
absolutely love to Target in fantasy
it's just not going to be week one all
right do a few quick chats here uh
before we get out of here dilcash says
thoughts on starting Jared Goff over
Kirk Cousins Jared Goff has been so bad
on the road going to Kansas City it
would be cousins for me I think what do
you think about God first cousins this
week Leone yeah it's it's cousins for me
I know over the off season when we were
modeling a lot of stuff I was pleasantly
surprised with the Minnesota play
calling here and they're home they're in
a dome the team total for them is like
26 compared to you know 24 Detroit
doesn't sound like a lot but it's just a
few factors that are shifting in the way
of Cousins being more efficient more
likely to throw more passing touchdowns
neither of these guys are going to get
it done on the ground so I'm with Kirk
Pete is asking if Bruce Hall is a sit in
week one I get that people are scared of
Dalvin cook and I understand that they
gave down a bunch of money I think Aaron
Rodgers prefers uh or wants Dalvin cook
there and he requested that to happen I
just think Bruce Hall is too talented to
sit like yeah he's gonna split work with
Dalvin cook yay is coming off the ACL
guy's just too talented to sit unless
you had an awesome option I think I'd be
playing Bruce Hall in this spot on
Monday night
yeah Greek he asks do you think Stroud
and Nico clown Nico Collins click week
one
um you know I do think Nico is a nice
upside play over the course of the
season but man I mean he's kind of like
a double-digit round pick in fantasy so
I can't imagine that I'm starting him
really in any leagues unless they're
super deep out of the gate
uh last chat here last question from
Chad Rahul says Antonio Gibson or miles
Sanders at running back who should you
start so we've talked a lot about Brian
Robinson I gave kind of my take on
Antonio Gibson role we know that the
Panthers like broke the bank somehow for
Miles Sanders though which was insane to
me but they did do it so I think the
role will be very good in this game
against Atlanta what do you think about
miles versus Antonio Gibson
yeah
um it's tough because I actually think
both Washington backs could get there in
the way this game could shake out but
ultimately I gotta go with the projected
Workforce role for Miles Sanders so you
know Dome game against Atlanta it's not
a real high total game but
um I also I think Miles Sanders is going
to catch a lot more passes than he did
last year as well just the way he was
utilized in Philadelphia is going to be
different now in Carolina
all right this was a ton of fun just to
recap here the five spots that we like
for guys this week Joe Mixon Anthony
Richardson Brian Robinson DK Metcalf
Marvin Mims the Five Guys who we think
are in tougher spots this week Marquis
Brown Damien Pierce Naji Harris dong
Kincaid
and Quentin Johnston really appreciate
all of you being here and hanging out
with us for this Bleacher Report fantasy
football show brought to you of course
by State Farm four
Mr Leone
for everybody behind the scenes of
Bleacher Report I am Adam
good luck everybody